NARRATOR: Egypt, the richest
source of archaeological
treasures on the planet.
SALIMA: Oh, that's
a fabulous one!
NARRATOR: Beneath this desert
landscape lie the secrets
of this ancient civilization.
JOHN: Wow, you can see why
the pharaohs chose this place.
NARRATOR: Now, for a full
season of excavations, our
cameras have unprecedented
access to follow teams on the
frontline of archaeology...
ASHRAF: I'm driving so fast
because I'm so excited!
KATHLEEN: It's an entrance,
we can see an entrance.
NARRATOR: Revealing
buried secrets...
ANTONIO: I have just
been told that they
have found something.
DON: Oh my gosh.
(laughs).
JOHN: A sphinx!
NARRATOR: And making
discoveries that could
rewrite ancient history.
This time, the hunt for the
lost tomb of Queen Cleopatra.
Colleen searches for clues
in the hieroglyphs...
COLLEEN: Here we see
Cleopatra as the goddess Isis.
NARRATOR: Alejandro
scans ancient mummies in
an Egyptian hospital...
NARRATOR: And
Kathleen makes a startling
discovery deep underground.
NARRATOR: Ancient Egypt,
a kingdom of great pharaohs
and a cradle of civilization.
But after 3,000 years
this rule came to an
end with the last pharaoh,
Queen Cleopatra.
For centuries this enigmatic
woman has captured the
imagination of the world,
but the location of her
tomb is still a mystery.
Today archaeologists
across Egypt are on
the hunt for clues.
Renowned Egyptologists Colleen
and John Darnell are experts
in decoding hieroglyphs,
they're on their way to
the Valley of the Kings.
COLLEEN: We're headed to the
location of the burials of
nearly every pharaoh
of the New Kingdom.
NARRATOR: The Valley
is a rabbit warren of
sixty-five hidden tombs.
They form one of the
greatest royal
cemeteries in the world,
but not all of
them are finished.
JOHN: This morning we're
going to the unfinished
tomb of Ramses XI.
It's the last tomb begun in
the Valley of the Kings, and
many times unfinished things
in Egypt can actually tell
you a little bit more than
the completed product.
NARRATOR: Ramses XI
reigned over 1,000
years before Cleopatra,
but when he died his
tomb was never used.
COLLEEN: So here you could
see just the initial phases
of the tomb decoration,
but it's already a beautiful
depiction of Ramses XI.
We know exactly who we're
looking at because of his
cartouches, his name rings,
in front of his face.
JOHN: Looks like they've
laid out what would've been
remarkable illustrations and,
and texts early in the
initial part of the tomb.
NARRATOR: The tomb of
Ramses XI is located in
the east of the
Valley of the Kings.
Its cavernous chambers
and pillared halls reveal
how the pharaoh should
have been buried,
but the back of the
tomb is unfinished.
After 500 years
of Egypt's kings and queens
being buried in the Valley,
Ramses' tomb marks
the end of an era.
Ramses XI abandoned
the Valley of the Kings,
and no more pharaohs
were buried here.
COLLEEN: This is very much the
end of a legacy, this is the
end of kings being buried in
the Valley of the Kings,
but it's also the start of
something new,
of continued royal burial
that really ends with Cleopatra.
NARRATOR: Historians believe
this royal burial site was
abandoned because of looting,
but no one has found the
cemetery for the last
pharaohs of Egypt,
Cleopatra and
her family line.
So where could it be?
After the Valley fell out
of use eventually Egypt's
seat of power
shifted north to Alexandria.
The last great dynasty of
pharaohs established their
capital here to exploit
trade across
the Mediterranean Sea.
Archaeologist Dr. Ross Thomas
from the British Museum
is here exploring the ancient
capital for evidence that
could lead to Cleopatra.
ROSS: The ancient city housed
about half a million people
during the first century BC
and it was one of the most
important ancient ports
and ancient cities
of the Mediterranean.
NARRATOR: The port city
of Alexandria was founded
by Alexander the Great
who conquered Egypt
2,300 years ago.
It was famed for its palaces,
statues, its library, and a
colossal lighthouse standing
over 350 feet tall, one
of the seven wonders
of the ancient world.
During this time,
Egypt was ruled by the
successors of Alexander,
the Greek pharaohs
called the Ptolemies,
but this family line ended
when the country was eventually
conquered by Rome,
leaving the last pharaoh
of Egypt Queen Cleopatra.
Many archaeologists think
Cleopatra will be found in a
royal cemetery somewhere in
Alexandria, the capital
built by her own family...
but searching
here is difficult.
The ancient city was hit by
a series of earthquakes and
much of it now
lies beneath the waves.
ROSS: So do we
have weights here?
MAN: Yes.
NARRATOR: Professor
Emad Khalil from Alexandria
University began exploring
the sunken city over twenty
years ago, keeping an eagle
eye out for Cleopatra's tomb.
EMAD: This has not been found
obviously in Alexandria yet,
but as we always say
beneath Alexandria there
are other Alexandrias.
Okay.
NARRATOR: The evidence of
Cleopatra's ancient capital
is strewn across the seabed.
Shards of pottery,
huge columns,
fallen obelisks,
and what they believe is one
of the doorways to
the famous lighthouse.
ROSS: There was scores of
columns and column bases,
hundreds of blocks,
really large
structural blocks.
EMAD: I think we managed
to see a part of an obelisk,
and part of a
doorway of the lighthouse,
so it is, it's really,
really something.
ROSS: Yeah.
NARRATOR: Every
dive provides new data for
Emad and Ross to research,
but there's no
sign of Cleopatra or
her family's graves.
EMAD: Well you'd assume
that they'd want to be
buried in their own city.
Normally what you
have is a royal cemetery
with all the burials
for the kings and queens.
NARRATOR: But what if
Cleopatra wasn't buried
in Alexandria at all?
One woman thinks
everyone has been looking
in the wrong place.
Thirty miles west of
Alexandria in an ancient city
called Taposiris Magna,
there is a
little-known temple.
Here Kathleen Martinez,
a qualified lawyer turned
archaeologist, is on a quest.
KATHLEEN: So this is one
of the exciting moments
of an excavation.
NARRATOR: For the past decade
she has been building a case
that Queen Cleopatra is buried
beneath this temple.
KATHLEEN: I want to
be an archaeologist
since I was a child,
but my parents convinced
me to study law, and I
became a lawyer.
But all this knowledge and
this information that I had
as a lawyer I combine with
archaeology, and this is
how I follow Cleopatra's
steps to Taposiris Magna.
NARRATOR: Kathleen is from
the Dominican Republic in the
Caribbean, but thirteen years
ago she gave up her law
work and started excavating
here at the temple.
KATHLEEN: We have uncovered so
many important structures that
prove this temple functioned
as a temple during the
time of Queen Cleopatra
and the Greek pharaohs.
So this could be
the perfect place for
Cleopatra's lost tomb.
NARRATOR: At the age of
eighteen, Cleopatra became
pharaoh when her father
Ptolemy the twelfth died.
She went on to rule
for twenty-one years.
Faced with the threat of a
Roman invasion, she formed
alliances with the enemy,
first wooing Julius Caesar
and bearing his child,
followed by a
relationship with Mark Antony.
But in 31 BC
the Roman navy, led by
Octavian, attacked Egypt.
To avoid capture, legend
has it that Cleopatra
committed suicide with
the bite of
a venomous snake.
KATHLEEN: She threatened Rome
and Romans were afraid of her.
She thought she could
conquer the world, even
though she was a woman.
She was a warrior, and she
achieved the impossible, and
this is why she is my heroine
and I will try to
do everything I can
to find her tomb.
NARRATOR: Kathleen believes
Cleopatra could be buried
somewhere around the site.
This season, she has
a promising lead 300 feet
outside the temple walls;
a strange
hollow in the ground.
KATHLEEN: We found
a cut, it's a cut in the
bedrock, it's a shaft,
and we are trying to find
out what, where it lead us.
NARRATOR: Kathleen believes
the shaft could lead to
Cleopatra's lost tomb,
hidden deep underground,
but trying to excavate
this site is dangerous.
KATHLEEN: It's dangerous
because if the bucket turned
around it could hit the guys
which are down there.
NARRATOR: With the potential
to break through into an
underground cavity,
they're worried the
floor of the shaft
could suddenly collapse.
KATHLEEN: It's an entrance,
we can see an entrance.
NARRATOR: It's a
huge discovery.
The shaft leads to an
underground tunnel.
KATHLEEN: It's so exciting.
I need to see
what is in there.
It has been hidden
for 2,000 years.
NARRATOR: Across Egypt, the
hunt for lost tombs continues.
500 miles south of Alexandria
is the ancient city of Aswan.
It's here that
Spanish archaeologist
Alejandro Jiménez-Serrano
leads a large
mission working at
the ancient necropolis
of Qubbet el-Hawa.
The site is home to one
of the largest sets of
intact tombs in Egypt.
Alejandro is
searching for unmarked
graves and lost tombs.
(speaking in native language).
This sprawling site is even
older than the Valley of the
Kings, and is thought to be
the burial site of
many wealthy nobles.
Today he's working in one of
the ancient tombs, trying to
identify who was buried there.
ALEJANDRO: Unfortunately,
it has no inscriptions so we
don't the owner or the family
who occupy this tomb.
We can only say which period,
when it was built,
because of the style.
NARRATOR: But deep inside
this tomb the team has just
unearthed two buried mummies.
As they clear away the
sand, Alejandro makes
a startling discovery;
it's the edge of a beautiful
golden death mask.
ALEJANDRO: Wow!
NARRATOR: Death masks are
often made of layers of linen
or recycled papyrus, and then
soaked in plaster.
This forms a tough
material a bit like paper
mache, called cartonnage.
While still wet, the
cartonnage is molded to
resemble the face of the
deceased, and then painted.
Often the name of the person
was written on the mask, along
with inscriptions to help
transport the deceased
into the afterlife.
This ancient funeral
practice continued for
over 2,000 years,
right up to
the time of Cleopatra.
ALEJANDRO: And the quality
of the cartonnage is,
is amazing, the, the colors,
and it has text and it seems
that it will be possible to read
the name of the original owner.
NARRATOR: But before
Alejandro can try to put
a name to this ancient body,
his team will need
to extract the fragile mask.
They use soft paintbrushes
to remove the sand grain by
grain, and then strengthen the
mask with paper
coated with resin to
stop it from breaking.
ALEJANDRO: It's a privilege
and it's amazing to, to have
the opportunity to,
to work with untouched material.
NARRATOR: Back at
Taposiris Magna...
KATHLEEN: They take
such good care of me.
They are not used to women
going down the shaft.
NARRATOR: Kathleen
Martinez is descending into
a 2,000-year-old shaft.
KATHLEEN: Yes.
Going down.
NARRATOR: She believes it
could lead her to the lost
tomb of Queen Cleopatra.
But there's a problem.
KATHLEEN: God! The
tunnels are full of water.
NARRATOR: The vertical shaft
descends twenty-feet down and
leads to two narrow tunnels.
KATHLEEN: We have tunnel
which is perfectly
cut in the bedrock.
One it seems to lead
to the north, and the
other goes to the south.
NARRATOR: The fact that the
tunnels are flooded makes
any further exploration very
difficult, but Kathleen
is determined to push on.
KATHLEEN: Okay, look.
Oh God, so creepy, look!
At the end of the
tunnel there is a door,
but it's almost completely
covered with water.
NARRATOR: Now she
can see the quality of the
stonework and how much effort
it would've taken to create
these tunnels.
Kathleen is sure they must
lead to somewhere important.
KATHLEEN: I tried to go inside
but then the, the level is
deeper and I almost fall down,
so I need to pump
up the water.
I have to, I have to
explore this door.
♪ ♪
(speaking in native language)
NARRATOR: Kathleen will need
to find a water pump before
she can explore the flooded
tunnels any further.
KATHLEEN: You cannot walk
there, or crawl, because of
the water, it's, it's unsafe.
It will one of the
greatest adventures in the
excavation now because we
need to know what is in there.
NARRATOR: Kathleen is
convinced Cleopatra's lost
tomb is hidden somewhere
around this site.
She has evidence the
temple is linked to the
Egyptian goddess Isis.
Kathleen thinks this is
her biggest clue so far.
KATHLEEN: We have
archaeological evidence that
the temple was maybe the most
important religious
center for Isis in the north,
and the thing we know
about Queen Cleopatra is
that she was buried
in a temple of Isis.
So it could be a perfect place
for Cleopatra's lost tomb.
NARRATOR: But who was
Isis, and how is she
connected to Cleopatra?
380 miles south
of Taposiris Magna on the
banks of the river Nile,
parts of this vast temple
site are dedicated to Isis,
who was a well-loved
Egyptian goddess in
Cleopatra's time.
It's here
that Dr. Colleen Darnell
continues her own search for
clues to Cleopatra's life,
written in the hieroglyphs.
COLLEEN: We're walking
to the temple at Dendera,
and one of the most
significant scenes here is
a depiction of Cleopatra.
NARRATOR:
The temple was first
built 2,000-years ago and
became a major
place of worship for
ordinary Egyptians.
Through the centuries,
a succession
of pharaohs carved their
names and images here so
they could be worshipped,
including Cleopatra.
COLLEEN: So the title here
is lord of the two lands,
referring to Upper and
Lower Egypt, Cleo-pat-ra.
NARRATOR: Cleopatra
made a shrewd decision;
on the temple she wears
the symbolic headdress of Isis.
COLLEEN: Here we see the
famous representation of
Cleopatra as Goddess Isis.
Here we have Cleopatra
and her son Caesarion.
So Cleopatra has a long wig,
the horns and sun disk, and
ostrich feathers behind that.
NARRATOR: Cleopatra
wanted to be seen by
her subjects as the earthly
incarnation of Isis.
She was making a
profound connection with
one of the most popular
goddesses of the time.
Isis was famed for
her powers of healing and
protection and was adored by
both Egyptians and Greeks.
By immortalizing herself
as Isis on the temple wall,
Cleopatra hoped to keep the
full support and love of
her people, and it worked.
COLLEEN: For Cleopatra
to step into the role of
Isis really proclaimed her
identity as divine ruler.
NARRATOR: At Taposiris Magna,
Kathleen thinks
Cleopatra's Isis
connection could mean
she's buried somewhere
beneath the temple.
Now, the team is pumping
out the water from the
flooded underground tunnels,
but it's going to take a
while before she can explore.
KATHLEEN: It's working.
Alhamdulillah.
It's a big relief
to see it working.
Imagine, today or
tomorrow we, we're going
to be able to, to explore.
It's so exciting!
NARRATOR: Kathleen believes
Cleopatra could be buried
in an underground chamber,
and the tunnels
could lead her to it.
She originally found
the location of the shaft
using radar technology,
but with the potential
for a huge discovery
just feet away,
she has brought
in more sensitive
military-grade equipment to
look deeper into the rock.
KATHLEEN: For me the
future of the excavation is
ground-penetrating radar.
It's a technology that was
used for military purposes,
searching for tunnels and
searching for cavities, and
this technology is perfect
for what I am looking for.
So we, we can work here,
make a profile here?
NARRATOR: As they move
the radar scanner along,
it fires radio wave pulses
into the ground.
MAN: So here we are going about,
about 15 meter depth.
NARRATOR: The data from
the scan will have to be
sent away for analysis.
It should reveal any hollow
cavities hidden underground,
and possibly even the location
of Cleopatra's burial chamber.
KATHLEEN: I always, you
know, so excited about this.
NARRATOR: Back at the
excavation site, everything
is resting on the team pumping
the water from the
underground tunnels.
NARRATOR: While work
continues at the dig,
in Cairo,
Kathleen is attending an
important event.
WOMAN: It's nice.
KATHLEEN: It,
what do you think?
WOMAN: It's nice, oh my God!
NARRATOR: At the Egyptian
Museum, hundreds of Kathleen's
finds have been chosen
to go on display
for the very first time.
They all come from her
site at Taposiris Magna,
unearthed over ten
years of excavation.
Kathleen believes
each piece adds further weight
to her theory that Cleopatra
could be buried there.
KATHLEEN: We, we discover
around 200 coins.
For example, this is a
coin of Queen Cleopatra.
Can you imagine that I've been
searching for Queen Cleopatra
and this is the first time I
was face to face with my
heroine, it was a moment
so exciting in excavation.
Yes, we are going
to change this one.
WOMAN: This one?
I get it.
KATHLEEN: For this one, yes.
I was thinking now,
when I was a kid in the
Dominican Republic and
I dream one day to
make discoveries in Egypt,
and everybody in Dominican,
my teachers, my parents,
told me this will never happen,
and now we are
presenting 350 objects.
NARRATOR: For
someone who started as
an amateur archaeologist,
Kathleen now has the eyes of
the world looking at her finds.
KATHLEEN: We had a
desire to change history.
It's one of the greatest
moments in my life.
Of course, the exhibition,
it's only a presentation
of work, but the real work,
the one we're really excited
about, is to be onsite and,
and continue searching.
NARRATOR: Back at
the dig site, there's a
problem with the water pump.
KATHLEEN: Mohamed,
what happened?
KATHLEEN: Cut?
MOHAMED Cut, yeah.
KATHLEEN: It's
not working now?
KATHLEEN: Can you imagine
after all this effort
now there's no electricity
in the area, and only a
few hours left today and next,
and tomorrow, that's it.
NARRATOR: Kathleen's
government permit to
dig at the site only lasts
for one more day.
She's now racing against
the clock to explore
the underground tunnels.
KATHLEEN: We face so many
challenges, but we don't,
we, we never give up.
NARRATOR: At the
4,000-year old necropolis
of Qubbet el-Hawa...
(speaking in native language).
NARRATOR: Alejandro's
team has unearthed a very
rare death mask made of a
material called cartonnage.
He hopes the mask will
tell him the name of the
person buried in the tomb,
but decoding the hieroglyphs
is proving difficult.
ALEJANDRO: I cannot
read properly the,
the, all the signs.
It will be
better to do it after the
consolidation and cleaning.
NARRATOR: Alejandro's
team has started
the painstaking process of
extracting the mask.
Their job is made even
harder because it's embedded
under the bones of its owner.
ALEJANDRO: It's quite a
delicate moment because we
have human remains that are
touching and we don't want
to destroy the cartonnage.
MARTINA: They are taking
off the cartonnage.
NARRATOR: The ancient
mask is carefully removed,
but comes out in
several parts, held
together with resin and
paper to prevent
any further damage.
MARTINA: It is really amazing.
(speaking in native language).
And I'm simply now checking
if there was name or not.
Yes, there are
more hieroglyphs.
ALEJANDRO: Here is
the name, it's for the
soul of Seti Hacaib a Inet.
NARRATOR: Alejandro
can now put a name
to the unknown body,
but he still doesn't
know the persons job,
or role in society.
ALEJANDRO: We have
now to look in the, in
the publications to see
if we have any reference
in the neighborhood or
in other documents,
and but it, it's amazing.
NARRATOR: The death mask
is now taken to their on-site
lab for further analysis.
The team will try to
piece it back together
like a jigsaw puzzle.
There could still be more
secrets to be revealed
about this mysterious man.
In Aswan, on the
other side of the site,
Alejandro has unearthed
several mummies still intact.
He's searching for
clues to their identity,
which may lie hidden within
the ancient bandages,
but to keep
them intact archaeologists
are no longer allowed to
open up the wrappings.
ALEJANDRO: 100 years
ago it was common just
to cut the wrappings.
Today we are lucky to
have non-invasive techniques,
and the idea is that we are
going to take to the university
hospital in Aswan where they
have very good CT scans.
NARRATOR: By scanning the
bodies, Alejandro hopes to
examine how they died, and
also to see if
there are any funerary
objects hidden inside.
ALEJANDRO: We have the
possibility that he could have
a dagger or a metal object
inside, we could confirm
the age of death, if he
suffer any kind of disease.
Definitely the CT scan will
tell us a lot of information.
NARRATOR: In the Valley of
the Kings, John and Colleen
Darnell continue their search
for clues to Cleopatra's
life and untimely death.
Deep in the tomb of Pharaoh
Seti I the first, they're
examining inscriptions that
could shed light on
how Cleopatra chose
to commit suicide.
The tombs of the
Valley of the Kings were
built during a golden age
in Egyptian civilization.
Treasures and
decorations reveal
the symbolism that played
a key role in
their belief system.
The tomb of Pharaoh
Seti the first lies in the
southeast of the Valley,
it's the deepest and most
widely decorated.
Painted on its walls
are images of gods and
goddesses who lay at the
heart of Egyptian society.
Forming a belief
system that continued
until Cleopatra's time.
COLLEEN: Here deep in
the tomb of Seti I we
see a fantastic depiction of
the goddess Wadjet,
she's labelled here in
the hieroglyphs and she
is the cobra who sits on the
brow of the king.
NARRATOR: Wadjet was
the protector of Egypt
and of its pharaohs.
She often took the form
of a snake, usually
an Egyptian cobra.
Legend has it that Cleopatra
killed herself with the
bite of a venomous snake
when trapped by the
invading Roman army.
COLLEEN: This depiction is
over 1,000 years before the
suicide of Cleopatra, and the
fact that she chooses
this ancient symbol of the
pharaohs, the asp, the cobra,
to commit suicide,
she's taking the
ultimate royal symbol,
she wants to be linked in
to the earlier, the deep,
ancient past of Egypt.
NARRATOR: Cleopatra,
through her life and death,
was obsessed with the
traditions of ancient Egypt.
At Taposiris Magna,
Kathleen believes she's
getting ever closer to
finding Cleopatra's lost tomb.
As the dig season is
coming to an end, she's
desperate to see if the
underground tunnels lead to
a burial chamber.
KATHLEEN: Is it working?
NARRATOR: Her team
has now been pumping
out water for two days,
but power cuts have
severely hindered progress.
KATHLEEN: Maybe we, we can,
I can go down and try to
see and I will explore.
MAN: Shall we start?
KATHLEEN: Uh-huh.
I am ready.
Okay.
MAN: Bye bye.
NARRATOR: This is the
first time Kathleen has been
able to explore the tunnels.
NARRATOR: She starts
with the one leading
away from the temple.
NARRATOR: With the
way forward still flooded
Kathleen has to turn back.
She now explores
the second tunnel.
NARRATOR: These
tunnels would have taken
months or even years to
carve out by hand.
KATHLEEN: Uh! Alhamdulillah.
MAN: Hamdulillah.
NARRATOR: Kathleen
believes they must lead
somewhere important.
KATHLEEN: It was incredible.
Now we know a lot about
this shaft, unfortunately
we could not see the
end of this tunnel,
there was a lot of water.
NARRATOR: With her
permit about to expire,
Kathleen's excavation must
come to an end,
but there is still a
chance that the data from
the ground-penetrating
radar might reveal if the
tunnels lead to a tomb.
KATHLEEN: Now we are
waiting for the GPR results,
so I have to be
patient and, and wait.
NARRATOR: In Aswan,
Alejandro is preparing
for a night-time mission.
He's about to transport six
ancient mummies across the
city to a local hospital.
He's arranged to use
their medical scanner
after hours to see what may
lie hidden inside
these ancient bodies.
NARRATOR: For security,
a police escort
joins the convoy.
To try to know something
about how they were buried,
the pathologies,
the possible diseases
that they suffer,
the cause of death, gender, age.
NARRATOR: The C-T
scanner should be able to
see through the wrappings
to the bones below,
but Alejandro is still
worried about damaging
the fragile remains.
ALEJANDRO: Mummies
are very delicate,
so you have to
think that they,
they have been wrapped
more than 2,000 years ago,
so they might
suffer damages.
Well, let's go.
Hello?
Inshallah.
We, yeah, yeah, yeah,
we, we will arrive in five,
ten minutes maximum, okay?
Ooph.
We have to, to take
this opportunity to get as
much information as possible,
so we will see.
NARRATOR: Alejandro's
night-time activities have
attracted the attention
of the local press.
ALEJANDRO: I will ask
to the journalists please
to leave to the specialists
to make their work.
MAN: Please, which one we
will start now, which one?
ALEJANDRO: Yeah, this one.
MAN: Thank you, okay.
You're ready?
ALEJANDRO: Yes.
NARRATOR: The mummies
are wrapped in cloth for added
protection inside the scanner.
It works by taking
a series of x-rays at
different angles to create
a three-dimensional
image of the body.
ALEJANDRO: We are
just checking if the
scan was done right.
NARRATOR: So far, very little
is known about these mummies,
like how they died,
and whether they were
old or young.
Alejandro is
trying to piece
together their identities,
hoping to discover
any new clues to make
sense of their lives,
and ultimately,
their deaths.
The first analysis
of the body shows that he
was over 60 when he died.
So now I have to choose
who is going to be the next.
Okay? Let's go.
Well, now we have
something very interesting.
Interpreted that the mummy
was going to be a man, but
it seems that it is a woman.
We didn't, we
didn't expect that.
NARRATOR: As the final
body enters the scanner,
the archaeologists
spot something amazing.
WOMAN: Si.
ALEJANDRO: We have amulets.
Together with the scarab,
a wing, winged scarab.
MAN: Sign of Horus.
ALEJANDRO: Ah-ha.
(speaking in native language).
NARRATOR: The scan reveals
an elaborate carved amulet in
the shape of a scarab beetle.
Funerary amulets were often
used by the elite to protect
the soul of the deceased,
and the scarab beetle
symbolized rebirth.
The scarab was placed
over the position of the
heart and often had spells
written on it.
These spells gave
instructions to the person's
heart to help them during the
judgement of their soul.
ALEJANDRO: It's the first time
that I can see them in the,
in the position in,
in its position in the
body, so, exciting.
NARRATOR: Out of the
nine mummies Alejandro's
team have scanned,
this is the only one to
have an amulet still
in its original position.
With such a precious
find, Alejandro can wrap
up his night on a high.
ALEJANDRO: Now it's 12:00 and,
hmm, I'm completely exhausted.
Thank you.
NARRATOR: At Taposiris Magna,
Kathleen has received
news about her radar
search for Cleopatra's tomb.
KATHLEEN: Today is the
last day and the people which
are doing the, the radar,
they're bringing the result and
they just told me,
"We have great news for you."
So tell me what is
the good news we have?
KATHLEEN: Possible chamber?
MAN: Yes.
KATHLEEN: Wow.
KATHLEEN: I'm going to cry.
Really, I'm trying to,
I'm so happy.
It could be anything buried
there but I feel it's,
it's what I'm looking for.
NARRATOR: Kathleen's scans
reveal a thirty-foot-wide
cavity directly beneath the
entrance to the temple.
It would have taken ancient
workers a monumental effort to
build, and if it's a tomb it
must be the tomb of
someone important.
This could be the perfect
hiding place for the last
queen of Egypt, Cleopatra.
The tomb could hold her
royal treasures, and its
discovery would be one of
the greatest finds in the
history of archaeology.
KATHLEEN: So the
room is big, and this...
MAN: Ten meters.
KATHLEEN: Ten meters long? Wow.
MAN: Yeah.
NARRATOR: For Kathleen,
Cleopatra's lost tomb could
now be within her grasp.
KATHLEEN: I'm just really
excited and I'm touched.
This is something that is
really important, precious,
something very precious they
tried to hide there.
So I think this is the
final stage of my search.
NARRATOR: It's been
an incredible season for
Kathleen and her workers,
but with her
permit now expired,
she must secure the
site and continue her search
for the chamber next year.
KATHLEEN: Next season
I will come back.
This is the moment
that I was waiting for.
Now I know exactly
where to continue.